Oh,
well you're not really friends and
what's unusual is that I've even
operated on some friends and it's
changed our relationship because they've
gone from being friends to being friends
had operated on and,
and,
and I almost named their doctor now more
than their friend.
Um,
and it's different.
Uh,
you,
my father operated on folks in town and
had an interesting perspective on this
is because we're from a small town.
He usually new people he was operating
on any often found it odd to not know a
person who was operating on he.
He liked it better when you knew because
you felt more invested even though he
had complications and things go wrong
like anybody else.
Whereas in a big city practice,
I'm in Boston,
you know,
I,
I always end up thinking twice,
you know,
one of my colleagues operated on his
girlfriend's a boyfriend.
I mean,
sorry,
his daughter's boyfriend and it was a,
uh,
you know,
we all kind of scratch your head as you
said,
well,
you know who,
who better to take a look at this guy.
Um,
so I think the,
um,
there is a necessary though,
professional line where,
um,
people are relying on you to be
something more than a friend.
They're relying on you to be a
professional and to,
by being a professional,
that means I'm really thinking through
how to do things optimally for them,
give them their best chance,
worked with other people as a team.
And that goes beyond what friendship
requires.
Um,
it's just different.
Well,
in some ways it deepens it because you
understand their issues.
I'm a cancer surgeon,
most of my,
I mean I do general surgery,
but most of the patients I take care of
our cancer patients and I'm a.
and it changes it in the sense that,
um,
well let me put this way,
for example.
Uh,
I mean I haven't ever operated on
someone who's really my best friend and
I'm not sure I would do that,
but,
but folks who are friends,
colleagues from work,
for example,
who are the same age as me,
and uh,
we find,
for example,
that they're not sure what to call me
anymore.
They always called me a tool before and
then they almost want to call me Dr
Gawande because they see me that way.
Um,
and I would say to him,
no,
call me a tool.
And it is that,
that discomfort.
You see them deciding,
well,
I won't call them anything.
I'll just say hi,
I'm the friendship can become both
deeper and yet a little more formal.
We ended up talking about,
you know,
life and death and their fears will,
this cancer comeback is often very high
in their minds.
Um,
makes it hard to just talk about,
you know,
boy,
that movie Avatar was not that good was
it?
I don't think gratitudes right,
the right word.
Um,
you know,
the,
we're getting so good at doing what we
do in medicine.
I'm not good enough.
Uh,
but when it goes well,
there's enormous relief,
but there's an expectation that,
you know,
that's the way it should have gone.
Instead,
I think what they feel like is there's
this person here who is the source of
information for me who can tell me
something about what's going on that I
don't really understand.
And so when we run into each other,
you know,
on the one hand we might be sharing cd
recommendations,
but you know,
inevitably they can't get out of the
room and meeting up without wanting to
just take you aside and say,
Hey,
you know,
I've been having this going on or that
going on and is there anything I should
be worried about?
And that discussion is very different in
some ways.
You know,
I want to be able to escape it,
you know,
let's just have a regular old
friendship.
But in other ways it is special.
I had,
I liked that connection,
being able to be helpful.